on va on va jouer vous allez pouvoir
gagner des places pour le cirque boorman
moreno à paris ce sera pour tous publics
150 passe je vais tourner la roue on va
jouer à fouetter c'est gagné fouettez
c'est gagné c'est très simple une
personne sera désigné par la roue pour
être le partenaire de rodolphe qui va
réaliser un numéro de fueter qui c'est
là qu'ils sont déjà fait fouetter
vous aimez tous les fous et isabelle sa
dépense et c'est moi qui le tient ou si
c'est moi qui reçoit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc on va mettre un objet dans la
bouche d'eric à un objet où on va
démarrer par quoi alors on va démarrer
alors ça c'est ça c'est ça c'est le
journal ça tout simplement d'accord une
journal qui a été donc voilà où les mois
qu'il met à d'accord que ce privilège
d'accord mais chapeau pour les ados
merci rodobe pas plus mal aux grives
également ou pas ont franchement au
remake teulé le bien avec al hallaj
comment ça va mais attention derrière et
cannes ayez pas peur rodolphe et ça
toute la journée
il en a fauté de la grossesse à cyril
arrêter de faire rigoler séparés par
contre bougeait pas et bougez pas mettez
bien non mais t'es bien les fesses en
arrière à mon avis non mais attention
attention roland emmerich paris car on a
forgé pour sac
[Musique]
attention
on va jouer maintenant on va jouer
maintenant avec un truc un peu plus
court voilà là on se rapproche de
thierry moreau
[Rires]
c
[Musique]
freud en excellence
ah ben merde on va passer à encore plus
petits pour inviter tous les publics aux
tiers
ayem était l'autre mais je passais plus
est plus petit ça un peu plus petits
après le but c'est pas la mouche et non
plus beaucoup de choses avec elle en
plus cela c'est pas possible ça je peux
pas
[Applaudissements]
jean cyr pouvoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à